allez on continue dans une thématique
santé le 22 juin dernier c'était la
journée nationale de réflexion sur le
don d'organes dr benjamin muller bonsoir
vous êtes médecin réanimateur et votre
ordinateur surtout du don d'organes et
prélèvements de tissus au centre
hospitalier de versailles on va
commencer par un chiffre du jour 40
milles
c'est plus de 40000 personnes en france
vivent grâce à un don d'organes alors
moi quand je vois 40000 je me dis pas
tout va bien c'est assez remarquable
sinon très important on peut gérer un je
donnerai deux autres chiffres 5100
apprend la première fois franchi la
barre des 5000 greffes d'organes en 2012
donc c'est bien ça aussi c'est un
chiffre important une activité qui croît
année après année mais ce chiffre de
5000 à confronter aux dix mille patients
qui restent inscrits en liste de greffe
à la fin de l'année c'est à dire que sur
une année civile plus de quinze mille
patients sont entrés sur l'iss deux
greffes et seulement un tiers au pouvoir
bénéficier de cette grève donc ça veut
dire qu'en france bdf on est dans une
situation de pénurie il existe
clairement en france une pénurie
d'organes
chaque année il ya des pêches patients
qui ne peuvent pas bénéficier d'une
greffe d'organe alors même qu'ils ont un
organe qui ne fonctionnent plus dans le
cadre du rail vont pouvoir avoir des
dialyses plusieurs fois par semaine
c'est très contraignant très fatigant et
dans d'autres organes défaillants le
coeur les poumons le foie notamment
n'existe malheureusement pas de système
de suppléance durable et pour lequel
donc le risque est clairement le risque
vital est engagé
et pour quelles raisons ça veut dire
qu'il ya pas assez de donneurs en france
ça veut dire que les français sont en
bonne santé alors illégales aux termes
il ya plusieurs éléments de réponses
d'abord faut bien comprendre que le don
d'organes concerne dans la très très
grande majorité des cas des patients qui
décèdent de mort dit de mort
encéphalique donc noir cerveau est mort
mais le mort le cerveau est mort fait un
accident vasculaire cérébral ou un
traumatisme et donc il n'ya plus signe
de vie cérébrale et ce n'est que grâce à
la réanimation aux techniques dont
dispose en réanimation qu'on peut
réussir à maintenir une perfusion une
viabilité des organes et donc ça ça ne
représente
moins d'un pour cent des décès qui
survient à l'hôpital donc c'est un héros
mort qui est rare et puis en france on
est en plus confrontés à un taux de
refus un taux de refus des proches quand
qui est globalement plus élevés que ce
qu'on peut il est de 35% dès 35 ans vous
l'expliquer ce taux de refus est ce que
parce que d'une mauvaise communication
est ce que mon inclination l'agent de
médecine avec ses campagnes de
sensibilisation justement on essaye de
sensibiliser pour que les les français
se positionnent je crois que s'il ya un
une attitude à retenir est un point
important à redire c'est se positionner
de son vivant sur ce qu'on souhaiterait
faire si on était malheureusement
victime d'un accident et qu'on décédés
de mort encéphalique parce que quand des
sondages d'opinion montrent que 75 % des
français sont pour le monde organes
concernant leur personne donc ça ne fait
que 25 à 75 % sont d'accord ils le
disent pas et aux gros majorité ne
disparaît au moment où malheureusement
le décès en mort cérébrale arickx est
toujours effectif extrêmement compliqué
pour la famille de choisir et à ce
moment là quand on sait pas quand on en
a pas parlé en famille bien on préfère
dire non peut-être qu'alors le ce n'est
pas effectivement la famille qui choisit
effectivement la loi française qu'est ce
qu'elle dit c'est la loi dite du
consentement présumé
c'est que si on ne s'est pas exprimé
clairement compte le don d'organes de
son vivant pratiquants se faire inscrire
sur le registre national des refus
on considère que vous êtes présumé
consentants pour enfin ça c'est ce que
met la loi mais vous arrivez devant les
monuments une famille dont le juge a pas
été abordée avancée mais aucun rôle de
médecin réanimateur et les mails et les
coordinateurs d'affirmer coordinateur
son d'interroger les profs pour
interroger le patient s'est il
positionné de son vivant premier élément
si oui la réponse est très simple
oui ou non et s'il ne s'est pas
positionné son violence qui
malheureusement arrêt dans la majorité
des cas eh ben on essaie de savoir en
interrogeant les proches ce qui l'aurait
souhaité mais là on comprend bien que
dans la brutalité de l'annoncé du décès
c'est pas toujours évident et les
familles ont ce choix in fine est à
faire
et ce serait beaucoup plus simple si
tous les français pouvaient se payer de
leur vivant et exprimer clairement je
suis pour où je suis content mais si un
jour ça survient les proches n'est pas
n'est pas prendre des décisions nous
expliquerait dans quelques instants
l'importance a rappelé l'importance du
don d'organes en tout cas seuil
seriez vous prêt à donner vos organes
pour un don c'est la question que nous
sommes allez vous poser dans les rues de
saint quentin on écoute vos réponses oui
parce que je trouve que c'est nécessaire
on en a besoin et j'ai une carte sur moi
qui qui qui dit que je donne mes organes
bah moi en tout cas si jamais je devais
être amené à temps mort cérébrale c'est
sûr que je donnerai mes organes parce
qu'autant sauver quelqu'un ce qui me
paraît logique
après si ça mais c'est un membre de ma
famille je devrai donner un rein ou un
morceau de foie ou quoi wyss le ferai
sans hésiter quoi oui pourquoi pas je
pense que c'est il en faut et puis si
nos 100 gagnent sont en bonne santé
pourquoi ne pas les donner
bah oui je suis prêt à donner mes
organes parce que ça puisse ovine dit et
tout le monde à la maison
déjà les papiers sur moi pour donner les
devants d'organes mais oui pas de
problème quand on est vraiment rabat du
bâtiment restera plus après plein de
questions dans ce micro trottoir à la
fin alors je vais remonter sur cette
dame qui dit je suis trop âgé donc c'est
trop tard banny à manage aussi il y en a
aujourd'hui on peut se dire pour
certains organes il n'y a pas d'âge
limite alors on pratique de fait on ne
prélève pas au delà d'un certain âge
mais on a déjà privé des patients de
plus de 80 ans au niveau du foie du rein
donc c'est il n'y a pas de limitation à
avoir pour se positionner dans la
plupart des gens pas tous les gens
derrière qui est d'accord donc ça
confirme bien les 75 % de français qui
sont qui sont favorables
il ya cette dame qui qui dit moi de mon
vivant je veux acceptera aussi donner un
organe parce que là on a parlé des
organes qui sont donnés aux semences et
le manque d'effort cérébrale la très
grande majorité des cas et dans deux
autres types de greffes qui sont la
grève essentiellement de rein est un
tout petit peu enfants fois mais c'est
beaucoup plus anecdotique il la
possibilité de faire don de son vivant
un proche
d'un de ses reins s'ils le sont proches
et souffre d'une maladie d'une maladie
rénale d'un stade terminal
je vous pose une question toute simple
mais quel est l'intérêt de dons
d'organes vous allez me dire ça sert à
sauver des vies
oui tout simplement quoi ça sert
effectivement à sauver des vies
vous l'avez dit il faut absolument en
parler dans les familles est-ce que
malgré tout quand une personne a dit
dans sa famille oui je veux bien donner
mes organes
quand je serai en état de mort cérébrale
est ce que malgré tout la famille peut
s'opposer au don d'organes c'est
compliqué parce que l'état loi de
bioéthique de 2004 elle dit elle veut
s'opposer le sait ces extraits
excessivement rare parce que la famille
se porte garant de la volonté du défunt
et façon ils restent très calmes un
respect des volontés du défunt
même quand les proches sont parfois
opposées quand il rapporte une une
expression très claire du vivant du
patient pour le don d'organes miles il
ils vont dans le sens des dernières
volontés du est-ce que tout peut être
prélevé alors tout près le nom tout ne
peut pas être prélevés on sait
aujourd'hui greffet six organes 10
solide le coeur les poumons le foie les
reins le pancréas les intestins et puis
on sait également aujourd'hui greffer
des tissus la cornée les eaux la peau
les valves cardiaques des vaisseaux et
donc on peut aujourd'hui effectivement
prélever un certain beaucoup pas la
totalité mais beaucoup d'organes et de
tissus
je reviens sur la cornée parce que c'est
souvent voilà ce qui fait l'objet d'un
certain tabou la corée c'est pas les
yeux alors justement le regardait
souvent à une confusion un petit peu
dans l'imaginaire commun
les cornées on enlève en fait la
lentille transparente qui est juste à la
surface de l'oeil et qui remplacé après
par par une grosse lentilles de contact
et donc on ne touche pas à l'intégrité
du globe oculaire donc les yeux reste
bien évidemment en place et qu'il n'y a
pas d'atteinte
au globe oculaire on touche vraiment que
sur la lentille transparentes qu'on
appelle la cornée c'est important de le
préciser que les gens pensent aussi
qu'on leur retire alors retire les yeux
le don d'organes est un don gratuit
c'est totalement gratuit et anonyme
gratuit et on l'a entendu aussi en micro
trottoir une personne a dit moi j'ai ma
carte de donneur donc on peut peut-être
préciser qu'il est possible de la carte
de donneur sur une carte qui permet de
se positionner de son vivant ça n'est
pas une pièce légal ça ne fait pas
office de pièce légal ça n'empêche pas
qu'il vaut spéciaux néoprène ses bras au
prg de ses proches pardon mais
effectivement la possibilité auprès de
l'agent de la biomédecine de disposer de
ces cartes de donneur ou on note sur ses
cartes je me suis positionné auprès
d'eux et on met les profs auprès
desquels on s'est positionné et un
dernier mot dr hubert quand vous quand
vous accompagner ces familles quand vous
leur annoncer un
mort cérébrale ce qui est effectivement
très compliqué et il faut quand même
aller vite pour prélever les organes
quels sont les mots les premiers mots
vous utilisez les premiers mots connus
si c'est d'abord bien faire comprendre
un premier temps que le projet décédé
parce que c'est des morts comme une
élection particulière ne pas le patient
a encore encore chaud et à coeur battant
parce que la ventilation permet de
maintenir encore une activité cardiaque
donc c'est d'abord un premier temps
s'assurer que les proches et compris la
réalité et l'irréversibilité du dessin
et dans un second temps seulement on
aborde le la recherche de nos positions
vis à vis de vos organes du du patient
défunt mais ça se fait toujours en deux
temps est d'abord bien évidemment
s'assurer que les leaf leaf à la famille
défend la famille par nos endeuillées et
bien compris assimile la réalité du
dessin merci en tout cas dr benjamin
muller pour vos explications sur le don
sur le don d'organes
voilà on va regarder c'est un spot qui a
été diffusé à l'occasion de la campagne
de sensibilisation et puis tout de suite
après on retrouvera sans transition
anthony rech pour le 7-8 sport met donc
tout d'abord cette campagne de
sensibilisation autour du don d'organes
je suis avec vous ce soir car j'ai une
chose à vous dire une chose toute simple
mais une chose importante
je voudrais vous demander de dire à vos
proches si vous souhaitez ou non donner
vos organes et voudrais vous demander de
leur dire maintenant
non non non non bah pourtant maintenant
c'est le bon moment maintenant c'est le
bon moment parce que vous êtes là
tranquillement installé dans votre
canapé avec votre femme mariée votre
frère votre soeur vos grands parents aux
enfants
bref vous êtes en famille quoi
maintenant c'est le bon moment parce que
s'ils ne sont pas à côté de vous votre
téléphone n'est pas loin donc vous
pouvez les appeler ou alors leur envoyer
un message à temps c'est le bon moment
parce qu'une carte de donneur ça ne
suffit pas parce que trop de familles ne
connaissent pas le choix de leurs
proches et parce que c'est justement à
la famille de faire part du choix du
deffand médecin et quand on ne sait pas
dans ces moments là c'est extrêmement
dur de décider pour l'autre mais surtout
maintenant c'est le bon moment parce que
nous pouvons régler cette question une
bonne fois pour toutes
en le disant tous à nos proches parce
que ça prend pas plus de dix secondes
parce que vous êtes au moins 20 millions
à nous écouter ouais c'est pas mignon
parce que ça serait beau si 20 millions
de personnes vivaient en même temps et
surtout parce que je vais le faire avec
vous
maintenant maintenant maintenant
j'appelle un proche web et allô papa oui
moment c'est mon frère je t'appelle pour
une chose très importante
s'appeler juste pour te dire je suis ok
pour donner mes organes
s'il m'arrive quelque chose non non non
pleure pas pourquoi tu pleures mais je
vais très bien je non mais c'est pas
pour déconner c'est pas si jamais il
m'arrive quelque chose je veux que tu
saches que je suis d'accord comment sa
vie non chérie les cheveux c'est pas un
organe oui tout ce temps mais non mais
ne passe pas maman je te le dis à toi et
tu lui diras voilà simplement parce que
les gens se servent au service est une
sorte de buffets de moi-même tu vois vie
non si je suis morte je pourrais pas
répondre chéri oui même tu l'as moment
pour tu le dis si jamais m'arrive un
truc c'est tout la mort empêche la
téléphonie mais on suit la longe le gang
dire à mon père que je veux donner mes
organes et fait pareil appelle un proche
oui je t'aime voilà voilà voilà voyez ça
peut être simple nous c'est fait et vous
don d'organes
il suffit de le dire maintenant